اطلاق كوريا الشمالية نحوها
عشرات الصواريخ هذا العام.
سفن قتالية للقوات البحرية
الملكية للتصدي للتهديدات
لكن المرصد السوري افاد بوصول
تعزيزات عسكرية روسية الى حلب
اليابان تدرس شراء خمسمائة صاروخ
امريكي الصنع من طراز توماهوك.
سوريا الديموقراطية التي اعلنت
تعليق تنسيق العمليات المشتركة
بدعمهم. وذلك بعد ان استهدفت
مدفعية الجيش التركي مواقع لقوات
العسكرية المحتملة ضد الاعداء في
شمالي سوريا. وفي المقابل طلبنا
تواجه واشنطن وموسكو. تتقدم
تركيا سريعا بخطواتها قبل ان
البلاد. فهل الانجليز جادون
بمواجهة التنين الصيني? تركيا
الاتحاد الاوروبي بسياسة الصين
الواحدة. مضيفا انه دعا الرئيس
لكن بكين لا تلتفت للتصريحات
وهنا اجتمع رئيسها شي جين بينغ
روسيا ارسلت الى الهند قائمة
بخمسمائة منتج للتصدير المحتمل
الجزائر تجاهلت رسائل اوروبا
لمراجعة سريعة لاتفاق الشراكة
محاولة القوات الروسية التقدم
شرقي البلاد. ووزير الدفاع
القوى النووية تجنب اي مواجهة
عسكرية. فهل تعي تلك الدول نصيحة
قطعي لاي محاكمة من هذا النوع.
لتعلن وزارة الدفاع الروسية رفع
لافروف وهنا ننتقل الى اجراءات
المحاكمة? وبعد اقتراح اوروبي
لايران. الدبلوماسية خيارنا
الاول لمنع طهران من امتلاك سلاح
روسيا من الانتقام؟ ليعود لافروف
مصرحا ان امريكا انسحبت من
معاهدة الصواريخ المتوسطة
والقصيرة المدى ومن معاهدة
الامريكيين بانهم من بادروا
بتسريب بيانات حول قناة الاتصال
الطاقة وانه سعيد جدا بهذا
الاتفاق. بينما تخفي المانيا
وقعت وزارة الدفاع السعودية
مذكرة تفاهم مع اسبانية لبناء
حركة الجهاد بعد سقوط شهيدين في
مخيم جنين. المستشار الالماني
نووي. واضاف ان الخيار العسكري
لا يزال خيارا مطروحا على
هذا فماذا تكون اذا? يقولها
العرب. الاحداث والتطورات. بعد
منهم الوفاء بتعهداتهم. ليؤكد
وزير الخارجية التركي مولود
الروسي الدائم لدى المنظمات
الدولية ميخائيل اوليانو. ومن
جاويش اوغلو ان بلاده ستواصل
محاربة الاعداء متهما واشنطن
والمناطق الكردية. ليعود مولود
اوغلو ويصرح من الخطأ ان تعتبر
العسكرية في سوريا لن تهدد
القوات الروسية ولا الامريكية
التنسيق بين الصين والاتحاد
الاوروبي. فيما اكد ميشيل التزام
غاز نورد ستريم. فهل سيتم تكوين
هذا الحلف الجديد لقتل مخاوف
اوكرانيا ضيفا انتصار روسيا على
اوكرانيا امر غير ليرد لافروف
من اوكرانيا. لكن الرد الروسي
الحقيقي جاء على ارض الواقع وذلك
برئيس المجلس الاوروبي شارون
ميشيل في بكين. وتعهد شي بتعزيز
الدول. فالاضرار من عداوة البعض
مقابل كسب الغالبية. رئيس
الوزراء الكندي جوستن تروبدو
يصرح ان بلاده تقف الى جانب
محيط الجزيرة. هناك وصل وفد
بريطاني لزيارة تايوان لتأكيد
خلوصي اكار قال الامريكيون طلبوا
منا اعادة دراسة العملية
دعم استقلالية لكن الصين تستنكر
الزيارة وتعتبرها خرقا لوحدة
حدودهم كما يقولون. ووفقا
للاعلام التركي فان دفاع التركي
القادم بكين تنفي ما جاء في
التقرير. فهل تذر بكين الرماد
المدن الصينية ضد الاجراءات
الحكومية الصارمة بسبب كورونا.
اخرى بل كرة الارضية مليئة
بمليارات البشر والعالم فيه مئات
والتعاون الاوروبي. ليخرج الرئيس
الامريكي بايدن ويعبر عن
الطاولة بحسب موقع فورين بوليسي.
اوروبا تضغط على الروس لكن الصين
للناتو وقال ان بولندا الان
وبصفتها الرئيس الحالي لمنظمة
اولف شولدز يقول ان اتفاقية
الغاز مع قطر اساس جيد لامن
البحرية. استنفار اسرائيلي حول
غزة تحسبا لعملية انتقامية من
قيودها لاستقدام اربعمائة الف
عامل اجنبي. المبعوث الامريكي
اكبر اربعة مشترين للاسلحة
الروسية في العالم لكن سلطات
انفسهم. مشيرا الى ان من مصلحة
الناتو ضمان سلامتهم. وهناك حذر
للاوروبيين. لن يستطع الامريكان
اخافتنا ستخيفوننا انتم؟ الصين
بسبب صفقات الاسلحة مع روسيا حيث
تعتبر اوروبا الجزائر من بين
مع اسرائيل خيانة للقضية
الفلسطينية. ان لم تكن خيانة يا
مع التحالف الدولي بقيادة
امريكا. لتؤكد تركيا ان العملية
ستشكل العمود الفقري لقوتنا
القاذفة في هكذا صرحت انستيفانيك
على العيون لتعلنها تايوان? تم
رصد طائرات وسفن حربية صينية في
يلتفت العالم اليها. فكل مشغول
بنفسه والعثمانيون يحاولون تأمين
كورونا ضربة في الراس توجع. فكم
ستخسر اوروبا حتى تنهي هذه الحرب
تكسب صفقة الحلفاء. كلما عادتها
دولة اكتسبت الصين تحالف دول
وبعد محاولة الامريكان الضغط على
هناك ضغوطات اوروبية جديدة وذلك
طاقم والقادرة على تنفيذ ضربات
نووية بعيدة المدى. هذه القاذفة
الاوكرانيين والبنية التحتية.
ومع استمرار الحرب في اوكرانيا
الى موسكو. ووصف مصدر حكومي هندي
هذه الطلبات بالاستثنائية من حيث
لمساعدتهم على حماية استقلالهم
وتعزيز قدرتهم على الدفاع عن
بين الاتحاد الاوروبي والجزائر.
والجزائريون يعلنونها
المحتجين في الصين وذلك في الى
الاحتجاجات الاخيرة التي تشهدها
دولار لتخفيف هذا الارتفاع. اي
ما يعادل خسارة اوروبا في ازمة
يستمر ارتفاع اسعار الطاقة.
وتتواصل الضغوطات المالية على
الصيني لحث روسيا على وقف الحرب
باوكرانيا. خلال ذلك وبعد تقرير
البنتاجون حول مضاعفة الصين
لرؤوسها النووية خلال العقد
تنوع مجالاتها. لتفرد واشنطن
عضلاتها. وتكشف عن قاذفتها
تكثيف روسيا لقصفها يؤكد صعوبة
الوضع في دومباوس وخركيف مع
ميزانيتها مائة وخمسين في المائة
للعام المقبل وتحديثها باساليب
الامريكي يقول ان روسيا اظهرت
قسوة متعمدة ضد المدنيين
الحكومات الاوروبية التي انفقت
سبعمائة واربعة وعشرين مليار
المتحدثة باسم القوات الجوية.
لنعد الى الحرب الاوكراني. وبعد
التحتية الحيوية تحت الماء، وذلك
بعد اشهر من انفجاري خطي انابيب
السماء المفتوحة ولم تعلق الدول
الاوروبية على هذه الخطوات. وتام
والنرويج عن بدء تحالف جديد تحت
جناح الناتو ولدى حماية البنية
بين البلدين النوويين لكنه وجه
نصيحة للبلدان النووية قائلا على
قتالية جديدة. الروس لا يكتفون
بذلك. حيث قالت وكالة رويترز ان
حرب المثلثات الى حرب قاع البحار
والمحيطات. حيث اعلنت المانيا
الدبلوماسية لتعزيز التعددات
القطبية ويمكن ان يتسع لاستيعاب
الاستراتيجية الجديدة والمعروفة
بالشبح والتي يمكن تشغيلها بلا
استعداده للتحدث مع بوتين اذا
كان يريد انهاء الحرب في
الامن والتعاون في اوروبا تحفر
قبرا لها ويقصد هنا منظمة الامن
بانشاء محكمة خاصة بجرائم حرب
ياتي الرد من موسكو سريعا برفض
تواجه ضغوطا من روسيا واضاف
سنتخذ المزيد من الخطوات
متهما الولايات المتحدة بانها
تمثل تهديدا وجوديا لروسيا
دول جديدة تؤيد التعددية وترفض
عالما احادي القطب بحسب المندوب
محادثات مع بوتين بشأن اوكرانيا
بسبب اشتراط بايدن انسحاب الروس
وزير الخارجية الروسي سيرجي
لافروف من سياس التوسع المتهورة
لاصحاب العيون الضيقة. الجزائر
لا تهتم للضغوطات الاوروبية بشأن
بتعزيزاتها العسكرية اليها.
واليابان تستنجد بامريكا لمواجهة
باعلان التشكيل الثلاثي من الصين
وروسيا وايران جديد في
كوريا الشمالية تستعين باسبانيا
لمواجهة تحدياتها البحرية. روسيا
مستمرا. ليؤكد ستولتنبرج ان الذي
يضم ثلاثين دولة عضو سيجري
للنايتو روسيا تمثل خطرا مباشرا
على امننا وهذا الخطر لا يزال
وورقة الموت. الغرب لا يمضون
يوما دون التفكير بروسيا
فالكابوس الروسي يلاحقهم في جل
اجتماعاتهم ليعلنها الامين العام
تستميل الاوروبيين نحوها. فمن هو
التالي برأيكم?
الناتو تحت سطح البحر والهند
روسيا على العلن وكندا تستفز
الصين مرة اخرى فهل ترد بكين هذه
المرة والاتحاد الاوروبي يلجأ
محادثات مع مولدوفا وجورجيا
والبوسنة والهرسك وهي الدول التي
انا مستعد للتحدث مع بوتين من
اجل انهاء الحرب. هل ما نسمعه
انطلاقا من اوكرانيا بينما رفض
الكرملين شروط بايدن لاجراء
روسيا وتركيا تمضي في حربها
وموسكو لن نترك سوريا وترسل
قاذفتها المرعبة الشبح. والمانيا
والنرويج تقودان مهمة جديدة لحلف
حقيقة? والناتو يدرس خطة الدعم
العسكري للدول المحاذية لروسيا
وموسكو ترد. انتم تحفرون قبوركم
بايديكم والولايات المتحدة تظهر